all right so let's just start the with
this usual drill so she's pushing and I
just changed the force down into my feet
and then so if this is where you're at
this is where you're at don't don't
brace don't do any of that okay and then
if you can I want you to start relaxing
so keep relaxing and and you can't let
contagion get you so even as you feel me
relaxed you have to keep going okay so
I'm just here and then if you if you can
do that and that's all if that's all you
can do then just do that just keep
relaxing relaxing relaxing then if you
can the next one I want you to do is to
start segmenting it okay so I am able to
keep the arm in place without the
organisation in place you see now I'm
doing that okay so again start out
I just want to relate my shoulders and
my hips pelvic tilt send the energy down
to the ground level to just relax
just keep releasing maintaining it
you're gonna see maintaining level three
I want you to start just organizing your
body you see that
[Music]
she's pushing you getting tired she she
pushes I push push me so I'll walk out
against your push push there you go okay
so I'm here and I'm gonna disorganized
the weirder the better okay okay so
[Music]
she's trying to knock me down knock me
down there if you need chances June so
the order was that the first one is is
relaxed so you can't see pushed push do
you see so what I segment
go ahead I'm not segmenting with tension
do you think though are the stuff relax
relax
pushing okay still it's still there ever
life I don't want to give you the ideas
you can't push because I'm moving that
so I just let my my hand wiggle do you
see okay so let's do the cross so again
a little one just redirect the energy
down level to your relaxing get out and
you can't you can't let that contagion
get you okay and then I'm gonna move
over here
[Music]
in the same thing honey
level one organization redirection level
to relax and then if you can do you see
I'm not the right angle if you guys see
that it's not here I'm not the right
angle and I keep Deb relaxed
and okay let's try it
alright so this time that force is going
to be back here okay so put your feet
together and just relax I'm showing you
this kit okay I'm over here like that do
you see that so I'm not still pushing
through her so I feed her and she gets
me here okay get her back here see just
relax
oh you might not be able to do it you
might get stuck but what you're going to
feel is that the energy comes back into
your face okay so we're back in here
long do you understand new kids role
okay get off
[Music]
see how push me back
I as I'm doing it I'm not gonna I'm not
doing that I'm just standing normal
aren't I sort of right I'm not leaning
into her just standing on and I wait for
her to get in position
I truly believe that the conditioning
can only come after awareness and
coordination so we have to have we it's
not a magic power and I can get stronger
as I do it but that's conditioning but
if I don't know the movement then I
can't get stronger so it's kind of like
the back squat it's very technical right
and if I don't do it that way but I will
not strengthen myself to the same degree
as if I did do it downward so there has
to be some awareness and coordination
before this condition okay so as you
guys are working your ideas we're trying
to find this awareness and coordination
and I come up with drills that make
these ideas get rethought you get the
case
so on this one
she's got all all mine push it
weightless okay so I'm not gonna do like
a Hangul things you see that I don't I
can't lean so much you know I mean like
I can't leave the race it doesn't matter
how your hands are you can see they're
not symmetrical
we could start out that way it's a
little racer so I'm just there and I'm
just gonna way and it's not like that
because you can see there's no strength
you wait on me right there's no string
lat
and I'm not trying to find angles so you
can play now I do the same
[Music]
change your hands
okay so get your deltoids I don't know
what to tell you okay so it just it
doesn't matter where where your hands
are for what we're trying to do okay so
she could be on on my elbows right it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
[Music]
do your best to just plant a
lady said she's she's pushing right
she's trying to push down there and I'm
just chip
yes try that
[Music]
I'm trying to do this thing I have all
these horses now
all right like you know with a kid you
have a better weight advantage right so
you can put more mass into the
techniques so that this should be easier
but if you if you do bracing angles and
something it's going to pull you I'm
gonna take that and I remember how it
was segmenting but the arm was staying
up there okay so I'm going to segment
with my arm no no go ahead and up the
arms going forward but I'm stake minting
that part okay it's not fun he's pushing
segments
[Music]
the desire to do some things with us
strike them preach them throw them move
them that causes the tension so when I
go like he feels that you see and then
your Aikido culture he does that you you
don't want him to feel that it is just
here boom you should be more concerned
with how far you get them to come in do
you see how far you get him to come in
versus how far you throw him out okay so
I'm just doing my drill me not treasure
throwing him I just want to step there
you Gator Mike tried to drive under us
you can't tell where it is you think or
as a Lego like that oh the morning
segment
[Music]